yeah baby
from a novice on the slopes to an
olympic athlete hi benjamin how are you
benjamin alexander only picked up a pair
of skis six years ago
now he'll be representing jamaica at
beijing 2022.
the biggest cheer is always for the host
nation the second biggest cheer is
always for jamaica and just by by by
happenstance my father is jamaican and
that just makes it a little bit more
interesting than if i was representing
another exotic or diverse nation i
believe
benjamin grew up in northampton and will
be the first olympian to compete for
jamaica in alpine skiing
he's one of only a handful of athletes
who've ever represented the country at
the winter games when you're the first
athlete to try something or to be a
forger for your country you have to be
the one to foot the bill for everything
you have to be the one to put your name
out there you have to wear a lot of hats
so you know like i've had to be my own
logistics manager my own manager my own
coat
now in his 30s benjamin turned to skiing
after a previous life as a dj including
a residency at the renowned burning man
festival
he qualified for the games despite not
even having a full-time coach and hopes
his success will show people it's never
too late to have a go
i've already identified the next young
athletes of jamaican heritage that will
go to the 2026 winter games and i hope
to use my experiences of getting to the
olympics right now to help them have a
much easier path how do you feel about
your chances for a medal or is it not
really about that i could get a medal at
beijing 2022 if all of the other
countries decided to boycott the games
whatever the final result his
performance at the games next month will
still make history katie barnfield sky
news